we are also learning more about the
highly classified U.S documents that
appeared online in recent weeks
according to the Pentagon these leaked
materials pose a very serious risk to
security giving the world a rare look at
how the U.S gathers Intelligence on
adversaries and also allies Catherine
Herridge is at the Pentagon for us where
they are trying to limit the damage
we don't know who's behind this we don't
know what the motive is Pentagon
officials are working to identify the
source of leaked War documents meant for
senior decision makers like The Joint
Chiefs of Staff Pages seem to be drawn
from classified military briefing books
including CIA updates not even the White
House can say if the crisis is contained
we don't know and is that a matter of
concern to us your darn right it is how
serious is this situation this is very
concerning Republican Congressman Mike
Turner chairman of the house
intelligence committee was briefed
Monday the access to these documents
would presuppose some access to even
additional and more documents that might
be of Greater concern or higher
classification
the linked information is largely
focused on the war in Ukraine with the
spring offensive against Russia
approaching the documents apparently
reveal Ukraine's reported need for new
Munitions so acute its air defense could
crumble a former Intel official says it
also indicates that the U.S and others
may be keeping tabs on the Ukrainian
president's conversations I think it's
really a new frontier in many ways H.R
McMaster former National Security
advisor and CBS News contributor says
the apparent mix of authentic and
doctored records looks like
disinformation Warfare the combination
of elements of Truth with falsehoods uh
to to advance an adversaries agenda he
also warns it could potentially impact
diplomatic relations some of these leaks
uh can draw into question are
reliability uh our trustworthiness with
allies we're going to have to do some
damage control
Pentagon investigators are tracking who
had access to the classified material
the justice department has opened a
criminal probe the head of the house
intelligence committee told CBS News it
could amount to espionage Vlad
Catherine thank you very much